so you did it we talked 3 years ago and
now it's real well the book is great I
think it's going to crush fingers
crossed but that's not a thing I can
control so yes about it but it already
did crush the way to think about it is
that it already did crush and that to
what extent do you enjoy writing I enjoy
showing up and then I enjoy finishing at
the end of the writing day I feel good
all of this stuff comes back down to the
process yes I said this thing once maybe
you agree with it but it's like amateurs
are obsessed with tools people will go
like what kind of uh
pen do you journal with like this
[__] matters at all right pick a
[__] system and stick with that
system I think it's not quite sufficient
to just say trust the process because
it's hard to trust a process that you
have not been through there's a
expression I like that says painters
like painting writers like having
written o
[Music]
nice and then you start the next one oh
by the way in case you have not yet
heard my book is about to come out it's
called Feelgood productivity how to do
more what matters to you and it's a book
that I've been working on for the last 3
years now it's being published at the
end of December 2023 but pre-orders are
actually available and I know people
don't like pre-ordering the book but if
you do pre-order the book and you email
me your receipt you will get completely
free access to a live exclusive event
that I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 2024 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world and we're going to
be going through how to figure out what
to do with our life and how to turn that
into goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe considered
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description so you did it we
talked three years ago and now it's real
we three years ago we talked on the 7th
of October 2023 which was like a three
years and a week ago that's nuts and I
was saying to you in that interview that
like hey Ryan you know I've just started
writing my first book any tips mhm and
you gave some really good advice yeah
and what did I say do you remember you
said you said so much stuff you said uh
the importance of structure okay the
importance of having your materials
assembled and kind of knowing what you
want to say before you begin to write
sure and the analogy you used was like
you're like well you know it would be
weird if you decided to settle from New
York and try and get to San Francisco
but you were just like you know what I'm
just going to walk and I'm just going to
figure it out along the way you would
you know it would be sensible to have a
map
although even I would say what actually
the problem is people don't even know
they're trying to head towards San
Francisco right they just know they're
trying to get somewhere and figuring out
where you're trying to go as you're as
you're doing it it's a bad idea that was
that was a big part of my problem in
that like the destination changed
radically like every year in three-year
process sure yeah well you do you do the
more the problem is you're trying to
figure out when you're work when you're
starting a book you're trying to figure
out the end result but you haven't done
all the thinking
required to know the end result yeah
this is why I think like the proposal
was a bit of a scum because the proposal
when I look at compare the proposal to
the final result there's like almost
nothing in there that that's like the
same that's how it is a business plan
very few businesses resemble the
business plan but there's an Eisenhower
quote he says um plans are worthless but
planning is everything and so I think
it's actually similar there in that if
you don't do a proposal this is why
actually I think most self-published
books don't work it's that because
there's no forcing function required to
get approval to start um there's no
deadline there's no constraints as to
how long it can be what it can look like
you can basically do whatever you want
which you would think would be an
artistic sort of creative dream but it's
actually like uh potentially a death
sentence how so how how do you think
about this balance because like you've
already made it you can do whatever you
want etc etc and yet you still write
books on seemingly on a deadline cuz
they come up fairly frequently like how
do how do you balance these well I do
balance it uh so I sold this four book
series on the cardinal virtues so I've
done two and then I finished the third
and then I pushed it a year so it's done
I'm taking more time to do it um it's
it's now like in in and the the
deadlines or the the releases the summer
of next year but
um there's a tension so on discipline I
felt like pushing it and it was actually
the right thing to push through and the
deadline forced me to get serious about
it and do it right and then on this
book I was actually more or less ahead
of schedule and doing great but then I
decided for just family and lifestyle
reasons to push it a year so am I
pushing it a year because I'm being lazy
or am I pushing it because I want more
time to do it well or I want it to fit
more in a more balanced bed way into my
life you know so I think uh i t i
function well with deadlines I function
well with the sort of day-to-day of it
and I think again people people think
that the perk of success is being able
to do whatever you want and weirdly you
actually find that once you can do
whatever you want you need to
self-impose constraints and boundaries
if you want to keep doing it well and in
a balanced way m
yeah I found that when the pandemic hit
and that was when I took you know took
time out of full-time medicine for the
first time suddenly my whole calendar
was empty yeah and I immediately
realized that uh oh like I kind of need
some constraints here and so I sign up
like art lessons and singing lessons and
piano lessons and stuff to give some
structure to the day and fit in the
YouTube and then some later some of the
writing stuff around that and I found
that that was really nice but it it it
always felt like a constant battle
between kind of structuring myself and
scheduling things things in
versus following my energy and like oh
you know today I have a lot of energy
therefore I want to film a video today
versus I don't really feel like it today
but like you know I I said I would do it
every day that whole thing yeah it it'd
be wonderful if inspiration was
sufficient but it it usually
isn't um and you have to build a
structure or a
system uh I think it's really important
anyway what is your like I guess daily
routine look like what's what's the
structure you've built around your um I
usually try to get up early I'll give
you an example though I try to get up
early I try to take my kids for a walk
that's like the beginning of what we do
and this morning we got up I got up
early I made their lunches I uh just
sort of having quiet time in the morning
and then my son got up and he got really
into Legos and it was also cold and so I
was like do I want to rip him out of
this thing that I'm that's also good
that's also I'm trying to encourage to
have a fight over a thing that might
spoil him un wanting to do the thing in
future times I'm going to say no uh so I
sort of ripped up the Playbook and then
I made them breakfast and then I was
taking a shower and then um literally as
I'm getting in the shower they wanted to
go on a walk uh and so we ended up doing
like we just sort of so I I guess in the
48 Laws of Power the final law which I
think a lot of people Miss is assume
formlessness so there's all these laws
about do this don't do this do this
don't do this but the last law is a kind
of a strategic flexibility and so to
answer your question earlier about how I
think about this stuff I I have found as
I've gotten older and more successful
that the rigidity that served me well
early on has had to give way into a kind
of flexibility now there's always a
tension or a a concern is that is that
flexibility actually just complacency or
laziness um and I have to question each
time why what is my motivation here but
but that rigidity has to become
flexibility or one you suck all the fun
out of it and two it's not sustainable
over a long period of time and it's not
it's very susceptible to being disrupted
or blown apart by the complexity of life
so I'm I'm less I have less of a routine
and I have more practices that I try to
do consistently yeah and I move them
around depending on what's Happening
what are some of those practices well I
try to get up early I try to walk I try
to do some form of hard exercise every
day I try to not eat until like I try to
have kind of a fasting
window um
and then I try to I try to do writing
before I do other
things okay so like I am flexible on a
lot of stuff but I don't write at 3 in
the afternoon because that's not
conducive to doing it well so so just
you kind of know what go it's more of a
an Intuition or a gut feel as opposed to
when I was younger it was like it was
almost it was almost a form of OCD like
it has to happen at this time if it
doesn't happen at this time then there
is distress and and that
distress you're almost doing the tasks
to avoid the distress which is not a
good way to live and how did having kids
change your relationship with work well
just blows your whole life up yeah in a
good way but it blows your whole life up
I remember this New York Times Reporter
was doing this piece on me right as my
son was being born and she she asked me
like how do you think you know like
having kids is going to change your
routine and I said something like I
don't think it'll change it at all and
which was of course Preposterous and uh
and very naive but uh it's just totally
blown it apart but it gives you
important stuff that you Center your
life around so like I think people are
concerned that like having kids or
getting married it'll tie you down and
it does it objectively does but it ties
you down to reality like it tethers you
to the Earth there are school starts at
a time and it ends at a time like
there's nap time there is eating time
there is activities that happen every
week you know there's stuff right and so
it prevents you from making it all about
you uh and it forces you to sort of
have non-negotiable things I mean I
guess it doesn't Force you you could be
a bad parent if you want but if you want
your kids to not be a nightmare you
realize like routine is very important
structure is very important but then
also rigidity is you know um impossible
there's um uh uh Lyn Manuel Miranda was
talking about how he had a kid right as
Hamilton blew up and
so he would do the play and then it's
the hottest thing in the worlds and so
every night celebrities attend and then
they come backstage and they go we're
going Hereafter we're going here he was
getting invited all this like incredible
stuff
and he had to say no to all of it cuz he
had to get home he had to get home not
just cuz he wanted to see his kid but um
he knew that his sleep was already a
precarious touch andgo thing CU he has
an infant in his house so if he stays
out till like 2:00 in the morning and
then he gets home and he's woken up five
times in the middle of the night or
whatever he's just not going to be able
to perform the night before then the
next night and so his point was that
having a kid actually saved him from
spinning off the planet from this kind
of stratospheric success that he has and
I I have found that for sure that like
again we think these things are going to
be baggage it's more like ballast like
it balances you out um in a way that
thinking hey I'm totally unencumbered I
can do whatever I want I can fully enjoy
all the fruits of all the cool stuff
that's happening you think that's what
you want but it's kind of a recipe for
disaster oh okay that's so interesting
to hear cuz I guess I've been I've been
feeling a bit burnt out from you know
the whole like rush to finish the book
and then all of the batch filming
podcasts and YouTube videos and the
audio book then and then like all of
this book promo stuff that it is
apparently sensible to do and all all
this kind of thing yeah and the
conclusion I came to a few days ago like
was screw it I just want an empty
calendar a fully empty calendar yeah and
I guess I'm sure if I experienced that
for a few weeks I'd be like ah actually
I probably want a bit more structur I
you want an empty calendar of the stuff
that you you want it emptied of the
stuff that you don't want to do so like
when I have an empty calendar that means
I have as much time as I want to write
and as much time as I want to spend time
with my family what I haven't scheduled
is interruptions from those things um
even if those things are fun or
interesting or
whatever ni by the way I was reading
your your bio it does you it does you no
justice it says 4.5 million YouTube
subscribers and it say over 93 million
total views yeah but it's way more than
that yeah it's like 4.8 4.9 now no no no
you've done like hundreds of millions of
YouTube views have we yeah oh I don't
even look at that number but you don't
really I made it a point early in the
journey I think uh thanks to all the
stoicism Kool-Aid that I was drinking to
only focus on the things that were
within my control okay uh to the point
that I almost never look at analytics
and the the only thing I can I even
vaguely keep track of is like oh oh yeah
I mean I was watching one of my own
videos and it said 4.9 million rather
than 4.8 million cuz it doesn't even
give you the sure know as you get more
the numbers get less precise because you
it matters less and I can see it in
YouTube studio if I go on and and and
stuff and I'll occasionally do that just
to look at comments and things but I
don't know I really try like the more
the more I look at the numbers the less
happy I am with the creative output well
so so tell me why
stoicism taught you not to look at how
your YouTube videos are doing them
that's very interesting to me I realized
that when I would look at how my YouTube
videos were doing in the back of my mind
there would always be that sense of you
know the whole like dichotomy of control
thing sort of like number of views on a
YouTube video is sort of in the in the
intersection where it's partly in my
control but partly outside of my control
um and I knew that if I like looking at
those I I wasn't able to look at them
purely dispassionately and I would
always get a sense oh that one didn't do
so well that one did or that one didn't
um and I found that you know if I if I
keep a general eye on the trend over
sort of a period of several months that
gives me all the data I need to be like
oh that sort of topic is really
resonating with the audience that sort
of video got like a th000 comments
compared to 300 that helps me figure out
okay maybe what like I should do more of
this and less of that yeah but I try not
to take it too far because you know you
get the whole audience capture thing
where you become a caricature
of um of the person that you're audience
initially initially enjoyed yeah and I
fell I very much fell into this trap
during the pandemic actually so um the
word productivity in my videos was like
really taking off any video with the
word productivity or productive in it I
was like it immediately like doing super
well and so I was thinking well you know
this does really well let me just say
every put productive in everything my
productive day in the life my productive
de setup my productive dating habits my
productive sleeping routine and all this
kind of
stuff and after after a few videos of it
like people in the comments started to
be like okay this is getting a bit much
and I started feeling icky about the
content because I was putting productive
in it to try and get the views because
videos with the were productive in it
were getting more
views I don't know whenever I I I I have
this sort of weird relationship with
numbers versus what's in my control well
it's it's interesting too
because it's somewhat in your control as
you're making it but then once it's out
it's done yeah but that's when we spend
the most time like refreshing like it
we' you've you you flung it to the
public you've put it out and now you're
like well do they like me do they like
me do they like me how much do they like
me give me all the likes right um
when if there was any time to think
about how something was going to do it
maybe could have been as you were making
it right but now that's over so now
you're really just moting about what you
would like to happen and the ship has
sailed yeah man that's so true like the
the way we do use analytics is in idea
generation and titles and thumbnails
yeah and that's the thing thankfully one
of my team members does because I don't
I I don't get joy out of trying to
package up a video with the perfect
title and thumbnail to make it click
baity enough but not so clickbaity that
it feels clickbaity right so I come up
with a concept that hey I'd love to do a
video about I don't know Ryan's new book
yeah and we were like okay cool we can't
call it disciplin Destiny cuz that would
be a bit weird we okay we've got to find
an angle of like the one habit that's
changing your like the discipline expert
or like how do all that kind of stuff I
Outsource that to the team and then they
tell me okay we've we've tested this
with the audience we think the best
title is this book made me more
disciplined and I'm like great I can
make a video based on that title sure
yeah and it's also it's not
just one of the ways I found it to be
dangerous is actually when it works so
um I don't know an article comes out
about you and it's positive or a video
comes out and it's doing well um your
book is out whatever you're doing the
thing and then you lose you lose a day
or more than a day just kind of Basking
in it you're just like refreshing and
watching like so it's not even like
you're torturing yourself you feel
crappy that nobody likes you but your
it's like your reward for succeeding is
a loss in productivity because you're
just soaking in this thing that's really
not in your control that if it had gone
the other way you would
be trying to work your mind around not
taking it seriously do you know what I
mean you'd be like that's not why I made
it what matters is that I like it what
matters is how it does it the long ter
you'd be trying to think through
logically why you shouldn't be
devastated by this bad news but then
when the positive happens you don't do
any of that and you just you just kind
of sit there and soak it in and really
the punishment though is that you're not
spending your energy where it matters or
where it makes a difference which is
like making the next thing or just
taking the day off like if you're going
to waste a day go waste a day don't
waste a day
refreshing your Twitter
feed I think it's that like Zen proverb
or something which is you know before
Enlightenment after Enlightenment before
Enlightenment chop wood carry water
after enl lighten him a chop would carry
water sure and I I often think of that
when it comes to videos and I I also
Suspect with the book because I think
currently I have an unhealthy attachment
to the New York Times bestseller list as
as a lot of writers do um but I just
really trying to remind myself of
whether or not the video does well you
know learn stuff write about it make a
video it's like that's that's the thing
it's like getting back to the process
rather than thinking at all about the
outcome when you asked me about
self-publishing earlier one I
experienced this unintentionally and
intentionally when the obstacles way
came out uh I'd already sold the sequel
and so in one respect that probably cost
me a lot of money because the obstacles
way did over the next year or two start
to do really well so if IID waited I
probably could have sold what became ego
as the enemy for a lot of money uh a lot
more money and I was but I'd actually
sold like a proposal version of it while
I was still figuring the book out so I
was under I I was still figuring doing
the work of figuring the book out but I
was under contract so I really didn't
care that the book kind of was doing
okay
and then I really didn't care that much
when it started to do well like that
right there is the the the first time
that book hit the bestseller list which
was five years after it came out oh wow
ni so I i' not only written the next
book but I'd written several more books
like I by having contracts for the next
projects I was just focused on doing the
next projects not on how each one did
and then with this four book series it's
kind of been the same thing like in 2019
I sold I basically locked myself in till
2024 2025 so basically like the next
four five years of my thing were locked
in so again the downside is uh courage
came out it did okay discipline came out
it did spectacular so maybe I could have
been selling I could have sold Justice
for more but um all of that was
irrelevant because I was just in the
middle of writing the book and I think
it's better to be wood and carrying
water then going re constantly
renegotiating your rate for what you are
going to chop wood and carry water for
or whatever you know what I mean like
like to just have the next thing so you
know if your thing is I make a video
every week you are already making the
next video before one comes out yeah
right a comedian comes up with an hour
records the hour then there is time
before that hour comes out and and it's
in that interim period that they're
already working on the next hour so if
the special comes out and it's a huge
hit they're working on the next hour if
the special comes out and it's not a
huge hit they're working on the next
special and you want to be in a rhythm
like that because it insulates you from
the thing that's not in your control
which is whether other people say you're
amazing or whether other people say you
suck yeah I feel like all all of this
stuff comes back down to comes back down
to the process and you know big what we
talk about in in that book is um you
know trying to find a way to make the
process enjoyable and energizing
um and yeah I find that when I have that
in at the front of my mind when it comes
to the videos or even even writing the
book you know like there were periods in
the book journey where I sort of forgot
to enjoy the process because the
seriousness of writing a book was like
Weighing on me and then I would read
like I don't know one of your like your
newsletter or one of your books or like
drive by Dan pink and I'm like oh it's
so good this stuff is so good and I'd be
comparing it to my first draft and be
like why my why is my writing so [__] um
and it would take my Editor to remind me
that you know the whole the whole
message of the book is find a way to
make it enjoyable and energizing so you
know well it's hard if people say trust
the process right but it's hard to trust
a process that you have not been through
before and so um once you've done it one
time you have a sense of the full scope
of the process or what you think is a
full scope of the process then you do it
again and again and again and you start
to go oh yeah this is the part where you
start to doubt yourself this is the part
where you get excited but uh like in
Texas we have this season it's called
false fall so it's cool and awesome
right here it'll probably get hot again
right like we think we think the
Summer's finally broken but there's
actually like several more hot days
coming projects are like that too you
think you're over the hump you think
you've done it and then oh wait no it's
going to get hard again but you you you
start to get a sense of The rhythms of
it and then you can trust the process
and then you can also enjoy the process
because you know it's like the first
time you go on a roller coaster that
specific roller coaster you have no idea
is this going to be one of the ones
where it's like this or is it going to
be the ones you right but then once
you've done it before then you have some
you can kind of anticipate it and you
know when to hold on tight and when you
can just go with it right and you can
kind of watch the other people that have
never been on it before how much scarier
it is for them and so I think it's it's
it's not quite sufficient to just say
trust the process because it's it's hard
to trust a process that you have not
been through yeah that's so true I think
like so I I realized this very um sort
of tangibly or so you know I've made
like 700 plus YouTube videos in my time
and I know that recording it always
feels like a total [__] show where I'm
making so many mistakes and there's so
much like crap in it sure but I've done
it enough times I know the final product
is going to be good because our editor's
amazing we'll chop out all the crap will
make it look amazing but then when
beginner YouTubers see the final result
and then they see themselves recording
and suddenly they're spluttering and
swearing all the time and yeah you never
see that raw uncut version of a
YouTuber's first take you only see the
final product and so now that I've been
through the process once with the book
knowing how crap the first draft was and
then seeing the magic of editing over
several months to trim it down and make
it good I'm like oh okay I don't so much
about having a crappy first draft now
well yeah you have your you have your
crappy first draft I actually have a
shirt there's a Hemingway quote and he
says I have a print of it in my office I
have a shirt too but he he says uh you
know the first draft of everything is
[__] and uh the the conceit is that it's
sort of showing how even that sentence
probably didn't write it perfectly the
first time but the idea when is that
every every first draft sucks and you
want to get comfortable with that you
have to get comfortable with the
messiness of the the process but weirdly
as you get better I do think your first
drafts get less shitty or less wasteful
right so like um you with your videos
and certainly I found this with my books
is that there is less and less left over
at the end because you start to be able
to shoot only what you know you're going
to use or you write less you go down
less blind alleys as a writer or you you
overwrite less because again you
know you know what isn't going to be
possible what's going to be extraneous
you have a sense of what you actually
need right so you're trusting the
process but also you understand the
process better and so yeah when you're
you tend to be overdoing whatever it is
you're doing the first time and then one
of the signs of Mastery or I guess a
trait of Mastery is the conservation of
energy like you
know when and what to apply at any given
moment whereas when you're just starting
or you're doing it for the first time
there's a lot of just kind of sheer
force of will and enthusiasm which is
important but often
inefficient
yeah yeah I imagine a video three years
ago maybe you shot an hour of footage
for a 10-minute video and hopefully now
you could shoot 20 minutes of footage
for a 10-minute video yeah it is a
little bit tighter now than it was
before um but even like yes especially
on the writing front initially my my
worry was I don't have enough material
and then after the first draft I was
like oh my God I have way too much
material yeah yeah um you
find that I think writing becomes a
process much more of tightening as you
go because you realize you just needed
to get it all down and then you're
realizing oh I've said this twice now
and actually here covers it over here so
I can they cancel each other out or I
can get rid of one so it's it's a
process of understand understanding that
so I have a question about productivity
for you because I feel like people are
obsessed with
productivity
and I'm not always sure why like I I
said this thing once maybe you agree
with it but it's like that amateurs are
obsessed with
tools right like what's the best
software to do this
is the way you know people go what what
kind of uhen do you journal with like
this fcking matters at all right the
what what program do you write with um
and if I was to rank the things that
contribute the most to what I do tools
are like not even in the top 10 today's
episode is very kindly brought to you by
heel now I've personally been using heel
regularly since 2017 when I discovered
it in my fifth year of medical school
and if you've not heard of hu they're a
business that creates convenient
affordable meals in a variety of
different forms but all of them are
nutritionally complete so they have the
perfect balance of nutrients carbs
fibers protein and fat and contain 26
vitamins and minerals and they've now
packaged some of their most popular
products into their best seller bundle
so you can try out all the heel products
and see which ones Vibe with you there
is heel black edition which is my
personal favorite because it's really
tasty and it's high protein so 40 g of
protein and all you have to do is add
water or milk and you can shake it up
and take it with you wherever you want
to go the bundle also has heels instant
meals which you make in the microwave
there's heuel ready to drink range which
are pre-made shakes in a bottle which is
super handy and I've actually grabbed a
few of these in the airport when I've
been between flights while traveling and
finally you also get some of the new
heuel bars which I'm very excited to try
out myself plus if you're a new customer
you get a totally free heel t-shirt and
a Shaker and pot with your first order
now I wouldn't recommend having every
meal as heel because that would get a
bit much but it's a fantastic supplement
to a healthy balanced diet so often for
me I'll have heal either for breakfast
or for lunch where the alternative would
be to to otherwise have a relatively
unhealthy breakfast and so heel is a
great way to make sure that you at least
have the basics covered when you are
living a hectic and or busy life heel
has very kindly been a longtime
supporter of the podcast as well and I
actually did an interview with the
founder of hu Julian Hearn which was a
great episode and that's in season one
of the Deep dive podcast so anyway thank
you so much H for sponsoring this
episode this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge fun Trader
who's gone into the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
pie might be like I don't know 20% Apple
20% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that pie looks good
it will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the pie which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of £1 so it's l literally free
money so you might as well so thank you
so much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode yeah that was kind of I was uh
as you were saying that I was thinking
yeah the tool is maybe the extra 1% left
over at the end potentially if like
writing in scrier is just a little bit
nicer than writing in a Google doc sure
but like this is the thing like as I've
basically tried to read basically every
productivity book on the market um and
then some it all fundamentally comes
down to really the way to be productive
is to figure out where you're trying to
go figure out what what habits and what
daily weekly routines you need to get
there then just sitting down and doing
the thing yes and then finding a way to
make the thing fun so that you don't get
distracted with other [__] and then just
doing the thing for a long time yeah and
if having a slightly I mean I have a
really crappy pen that I stole from my
brother now because my fountain pen ran
out of ink and it was such a nice
fountain pen but like I can write just
as well with a crappy B Point yeah the
the 1% tweaks um but it's so much more
it's it's almost like you know I'm I'm
I'm trying to trying to get into to
Fitness now and I just love researching
you know on running shoes should I get
this padding versus that padding been
for a run maybe once in the last six
months I love the idea of researching
running gear because it's great
procrastination from actually doing the
thing which is put on anything and just
go for a run yes or like just go to the
gym and do anything with Progressive
overload yeah it's like people are
optimizing a thing they're not doing yes
which which is never going to be the way
to get there that was a great uh a great
moment um that my my girlfriend told me
out out on this the other day uh you
know the whole like sauna ice plunge
everyone in Austin seems to be doing it
I was saying to her hey you know what if
I join a gym and it's like you know
depending on how busy the SAA is like
you know hubman says like four times
versus five times and like 24-minute
protocol versus 12-minute protocol and
she was like you've been to the SAA once
in the last six months let's let's just
go to the SAA first and then we can
worry about optimizing it later sure I
was like yeah so
true and know I think this obsession
with productivity it often feels
productive to be reading productivity
books ironically and re searching the
tools as a distraction from just sitting
down and doing the thing well the irony
that obsessing about productivity is a
form of procrastination right it's
giving you
the the sense that you are serious that
your heart's in the right place that you
are trying or making progress but in
fact you're not and you're avoiding the
hard thing which is doing the doing the
thing there is one aspect of I think
um there is one aspect of productivity
that I think is valuable to obsess over
and that is kind of journaling prompts
and just ask asking yourself serious
questions about why you're doing the
thing that you think you want to do
where you're actually trying to go I
spend a lot of time comparatively like
thinking is the direction I'm currently
going in actually the direction that I
want to be going in sure and I find that
the there's almost no amount of too much
journaling that can that can happen
there because you know in like an hour
of journaling I might land on one
Insight which is which would if if it
nudges my course even like 0.1% that
compounds over the long term well yeah I
would say being intentional about what
you're doing and then clear with
yourself about why and what you are
doing
is really
important whereas like productivity a
lot of productivity advice seems to me
is like optimized optimizing for how
you're going to pack your suitcase or
what your suitcase is is is or what
brand it is or whatever and you really
haven't
questioned why you're going where you're
going or if you should be going there if
it's the right time to be going there
any of the actually important questions
that are going to determine whether this
thing is a success or not yeah I think
the other unfortunate thing is uh you
know we we did a video recently that was
something like I read read 107
productivity books here's what actually
works and all of it was basically like
pick some goals figure out the method it
was like the the basic stuff and then we
made another video that was like 12
productivity tools I can't live without
and that video did so much better and
I'm like oh it's so annoying that like
the thing that had the meat versus the
thing that had the candy the candy
performs better yes and so RIT large you
know the incentives are there for people
who write or make videos or whatever
about this stuff is to lean into the
tools because the tools are the thing
that you know is the the people want
well I don't even know if it's candy
it's just it's it's concrete right so
you can
go here's this sort of ephemeral you
know metaphysical question about why
you're doing it what success is you know
why does it matter you're asking these
big picture
questions and by the time you get to the
end of it there actually isn't an answer
because it's about the question and
that's a lot less clear than the these
are the three best pens this is the
number one bit of software or here's a
really
interesting complicated system that a
successful
person uses whose work you are a fan of
yeah right like one is very concrete and
the other
is essentially ineffable right and so
you naturally especially at the early
stages one's much more digestible and
understandable do you know what I mean
like you're you're also contemplating
questions that someone if they're a an
aspiring High School insert you know um
is not even going to understand as a
question you know what I mean like like
Tom Brady talking about whether you know
how much is enough enough or you know
where to find deep motivation or
whatever
that's a lot for someone who's not even
competed at an elite level to think
about so it's easier to start with what
do you have for breakfast right or like
what what kind of gloves do you wear do
you know what I mean like one one is
much more relatable and accessible But
ultimately
much more
inconsequential yeah I do I do find that
there are some tools that certainly when
I was more of a beginner in the space
helped develop the Habit which was the
thing that actually mattered so for
example uh reading about uh how
different people do a weekly review is
quite helpful and I you know I
downloaded like the initially the PDF
template and then the Google Docs
template and now notion templates are
all the all the rage um but the point is
the weekly review journaling prompt
questions helped me actually do a weekly
review and a weekly review is just a
very useful Habit to figure out like how
do I do this week what what are my top
three things I want to do next week
great let's just do those things so
there are there there are some instances
in which a tool helps build the Habit
which when where the Habit is the thing
that matters sure but it's easy to take
it too far like I I find whenever I
rewatch your video about your note card
system I know I'm just procrastinating
because the thing you actually do is is
you write every day but I'm like even in
the car on the way here I was like you
know what if I had an analog note card
system and then I'm like no but I'm
traveling it's like oh well I get dang
it like let me look at the zle casting
system or let me find another app and
it's so easy for the mind to go in in
those directions because it's like Ryan
holiday has a note card system I also
find it's like um you know like people
who believe one conspiracy theory tend
to believe all the conspiracy theories
right even though it actually becomes
less likely that they're all true right
like it's like if you pick one and
that's your thing maybe you're right
maybe you're wrong but if you believe
all of them simultaneously well they
contradict each other so it doesn't
really work right but it's like I tend
to find people who are really into
productivity systems the problem isn't
that you
know that this system is not as good as
this system it's that they're missing
the point that a lot of it is a placebo
which is like pick a [__] system and
stick with that system that's the H like
you're supposed to pick a thing and then
that's your thing right and then you
stop thinking about it yeah uh the
problem is they're like first they're
over here and then they hear this one's
a little better and then they switch so
it's actually it's not the system that's
the problem it's not the tools that
that's actually the amateur quality the
amateur quality is the constantly moving
and abandoning moving and abandoning
because that's what's profoundly
inefficient right like like you've you
found the system and it was working for
you like I know actually at this point
there's probably something better than
the no card system but is it
transformatively better probably not
right so am I going to uproot the thing
that I'm comfortable with that works for
me that my old stuff is in for something
that's 9% better like if I'm if I want a
9% productivity increase that's pretty
easy to find you know what I mean as
opposed to relearning how I do
everything so uh back in the day I used
I used to be a a close-up magician and I
would perform at like balls and parties
at University and stuff and there was a
a phrase that was often um you know in
the in the World of Magic the the
amateur magician is is the person who
performs 100 tricks to you know the
amateur magician is the person who put
who performs 100 tricks to the same
audience whereas the professional
magician is the one who performs the
same tricks to 100 different audiences
yes or what to that effect and In The
World of Magic as well there was this
constant thing constant like battle
between you know on the forums there are
the professionals who are actually doing
the thing and then there are all the
amateurs being like what are the best
tricks and the professionals like it
doesn't matter just pick three to six of
them and just do them at nauseum and you
will guaranteed be a professional
magician and the amateurs are like oh
but like I've got $1,000 I want to spend
it on like this trick versus that trick
versus that trick it doesn't matter just
pick a few and just stick with them and
do them repeatedly over a long enough
time and that is how you get good at the
thing but that's a lot less sexy
sounding advice than this one this one
trick will change your life yeah like
I've been to conferences that have
changed my life but I'm always
interested when I notice people are
going to lots of them like the chances
that every single one is going to have
that same effect is very low right and
so it's like you should you beat the
casino leave you know what I mean like
um there's this tendency to sort of
Chase more and more when you've already
gotten most of the
games I had some I've got some friends
who who attended like a sort of $85,000
Mastermind weeklong Retreat type thing
and after day one they were like damn we
know what we have to do we kind of want
to leave and just do it but like we
$85,000 so we've got to kind of stay for
the next 5 days knowing full well that
like all of this is going straight over
their head because they know they got
the one thing and they just need to
execute on the one thing and then two
years later maybe the thing number 20
or3 will become relevant yes but by then
youve forgotten about it and you'll need
to go to another
event so to back to procrastination my
one of my favorite quotes from Sena he
says the one thing all fools have in
common is that they're always getting
ready to start right so like they're
going to do it tomorrow or they're going
to do it later they're going to do it
once they get all all the the materials
or tools that they needed so I did give
you the advice that to to start a book
you want to do all your research first
which is true and yet really the
important thing is that at some point
you start doing it yeah right and
because it can go on forever to sort of
preparing and analyzing and Gathering
and you know I just need this other
thing first I just but really what you
need to be doing is the
thing yeah it it always just comes down
to this it comes comes back back to this
um and I've I I don't know if you've
played around with this but i' I've
experimented with so many different ways
of doing the thing some you know when it
comes to videos for example Some Day
Some some weeks I'm like okay the way
I'm going to keep doing the thing is I'm
just going to make a video every single
day and then I'll do that for a bit and
then I'll be like okay but that's like
too rigid and I like want more
flexibility like okay cool Tim fah says
batching is good so I'm going to batch
it and Thursdays are going to be my
filming day and it's like I'll do that
for a bit I'll be like oh no but like I
missed that Thursday and then I'll be
like you know said batching is good so
why don't I batch in a whole week and
film 15 videos in that week and then I
can chill for six weeks and then this
was supposed to be a batch filming week
in Austin and I F nothing because I was
like I'm actually not feeling it so
there's almost this constant search at
least in my life for like this
magical consistent system that will
cover me 100% of the time um thankfully
we have still still been publishing like
two videos a week for the last six years
so it's like it's not hopefully you're
not going to take too much away from
actually actually doing the thing but I
wonder for you like you've been doing
this a lot this sort of stuff a lot
longer than I
have how how how often has your system
for doing the thing actually
changed um well I do a handful of
different things right so like but the
main thing and I think this is important
you have to know what your main thing is
right we live in a world where there's
all these other kind of supporting thing
they're necessary yeah not absolutely
necessary but I think they're
important and but still you have to know
what the main driver of everything is
and so for me that's writing like
writing the books is the main thing that
the other things are supporting the
writing of the books yeah and the
writing of the books is creating the
ideas and the platform and the brand and
all that make the other things necessary
to begin with so the writing routine is
essentially unchanged um there's little
tweaks here and there but the main thing
is like just sitting down and doing that
thing and it's not a thing that can be
outsourced it's not a thing that can be
batched it's the day-to-day of doing it
on a consistent
basis to what extent do you enjoy
writing uh well there's an expression I
like that says um painters like painting
writers like having
written um so at the end of the writing
day I feel good do I feel good the
entire time not always sometimes when
it's [__] working it's nothing better
yeah but if you that's the only thing
that fuels you you're going to you're
not going to be in a good spot cuz some
days some of the most important things
come it's one sentence in the midst of
two otherwise unproductive pointless
hours you know so I
enjoy showing up and then I enjoy
finishing and sometimes that middle
period can be
torturous so I was going to ask you that
like when you say Feelgood productivity
does it actually have to feel good uh
there there's one school of thought that
says it's all about finding the torture
that you can tolerate and it's actually
the ability
to put up with the grind of it that
separates kind of the winners from the
losers yeah that's the thing so I think
it my my thesis in the book is that it
doesn't have to feel good but it is
generally more energizing when it does
generally like positive emotions feel
feel energy feel creativity feel like
reduce stress all that all that fun
stuff and so the question that the
question that led to the book in the
first place was you know when I was
trying to juggle working fulltime as a
doctor and also building the YouTube
channel and the business on the
side it just felt like a huge amount of
grind in the day job and then a huge
amount of grind afterwards to do the
videos and it seemed like you know
everyone talks about how you know
Journey before destination and I
realized that I wasn't enjoying my
day-to-day because of this sort of grind
approach and so I tried to find any
tweak that I could to make it feel just
a little bit better and that's not to
say that it was fun all the time or that
it objectively felt good all the time
but I found a series of strategies that
meant that almost anything I could make
feel even just a bit better and if it
felt a bit better it generated more
energy and it meant I had more energy at
the end of the day to give to my my
other hobbies and friends and family and
stuff and it also made me more
productive so I think it's like you know
when it comes to writing for example
there are some some basic things that I
found was you know the first chapter in
the book is about play and about trying
to approach things in the spirit of Play
now play you know a lot of people have
talked about about how comes about as a
result of um often a result of the
stakes being lower so like Roger fedro
probably isn't feeling play when he's in
the Wimbledon fight final because the
stakes are too high and I found that for
example with with with with writing the
book when I when I was thinking about
the stakes being high like this is my
first book and it's traditionally
published and it's a big deal that would
suck the joy out of it yeah whereas when
I tried to lower the stakes to be like
no it's okay I'm just writing because I
enjoy it and the goal is for me to write
a book I'm proud of suddenly it became
more enjoyable so the same thing but
like just a different framing that makes
it feel no the Pro the problem is you're
not in the Wimbleton finals but you're
fooling yourself into thinking you are
that's where ego comes in and uh anxiety
comes in you're just you're just like
you're making it much more than it is
yeah uh and then you're actually
ironically making yourself worse at it
yes exactly you the other big one is um
you know the idea of power so we talked
talk about talked about in Chapter 2 uh
play power and people are like the three
main energizers that I found um if you
shoehorn a bit uh and this idea that um
we get to choose what we're doing like
it's you could be doing the same thing
but if you think of it as I have to do
this versus I choose to do this makes a
huge difference to how we personally
feel about the thing um I I really found
this a lot when I was when I was working
in medicine where you know there was one
day where um I I'd finished the end of
like a 13-hour shift and I was just
about to go home to be like yes I'm
going to go home and then the nurse was
like Hey Ali can you put an IV a canula
in this lady in Bay number four or
whatever it was and I was like [__] like
this is going to be another half an hour
job it's like the nurse has tried and
she couldn't do it and so this is going
to be really hard I was just about to go
home 13 freaking hours haven't eaten and
then I overheard that some other patient
talking about like oh it's so nice being
in hospital the doctors have been so
nice to me and things and I kind of
realized that I'd been falling into that
trap of thinking I have to do this thing
and I think Seth gon has a blog post
about this that I remembered at the time
which was you can just reframe that to I
get to do the thing sure so I was like
huh I get to do this can I get to make
this person's morning sickness better so
that you know her baby's better and that
she's better because I was working on on
OBGYN and it was just like this huge
wave of relief that came over me purely
as a result of a simple mindset shift of
like have to becomes get to well also I
think one of the things I add to that is
is like important things are hard right
and so uh if you are good at something
if you have some sort of in
um
you're like like I I I feel like each of
us has kind of a unique potential or we
get sort of certain
opportunities and with those
opportunities comes a kind of an
obligation so like when I hear about
someone who is really talented and
really good and then I get the sense
that they're just kind of half assing it
or they're
stuck or whatever it's not that I'm
judgmental but I find it to be sad you
know like what do you mean you only
wrote one book in 10 years like uh
you're not Robert Carol you're not like
you're not you weren't slaving away on
some amazing Masterpiece you were just
ill disciplined and you took the
obligations that I think your talent
came with you took you didn't take them
seriously
so I agree uh you should mostly be doing
what you want to do but I also think
there's something kind of sad and maybe
even pathetic about people who are just
like not unproductive but
uh maybe only partially fulfill their
potential yeah I was going to ask you
about this so you said earlier that you
know you sometimes ask yourself am I
pushing this book out of laziness or
completion complacency versus like out
of a genuine need for balance or
something like that I was kind of
thinking in my mind like why does it
matter like why why does it matter to
you if you're being La lazy or
complacent you you've written like a
book a year for the last like 10 years
or something up said like that
like Point like you have I I would argue
that we sort of have a higher self and a
lower self right and you know the lower
self says H just like eat whatever you
want uh work only when you
want um I don't know say whatever you
want don't think about consequence like
there there's this the sort of immediate
gratification sort of
short-term impul impulses that we all
have right that if indulged repeatedly
tend to get us in a place that we
actually don't want to be right the
person they don't have any friends cuz
they say mean things right they're they
feel gross they look gross they're not
in good health because they don't take
good care of themselves you know they
look back and they go oh I wish you know
I wish that hadn't take like if I gotten
serious about that earlier I'd have been
done sooner it would have could have
done more could have helped more people
whatever right so so there's this kind
of tension between like our higher self
and the lower self stepen pressfield
says in between is the resistance right
and so to me the question is is whether
I'm am I am I doing this because it's
the well adjusted mature responsible you
know right thing to do or am I just
doing it
because the other thing is harder you
know what I mean uh the other thing is
uh going to take more out of me and I'm
scared or intimidated by that
so I it's not like I feel like oh I have
to write these certain number of books
so then I'll be remembered forever it's
just
um so I just took today off but what did
I get out like what for what reason do
you know what I mean like so I watch TV
all day I sat around all day I if if if
I decided not to work because I'm going
to hang out with my family or I'm going
to take a long walk on the beach or I'm
going to read or I'm going to take care
of myself the that's perfectly fine
that's part of a a great life sure um
doing it because
I want to watch TV yeah that that
doesn't I don't think that gets you
where you want to go some people might
argue that watching TV is self-care and
so it's like oh I didn't work today
because I felt I don't know stressed or
burned out and I needed to watch TV no I
think if you're doing that because if if
that's actually what it is more power to
you but is is that it or are
you lying to
yourself so for you when it comes to
like writing more books I'll put it this
way recovery is important right like if
you work out recovery is important you
have to have a certain number of days
where you recover you let the
body rest and recuperate yeah um is that
what you're doing or are you just not
doing it because it's hard to
do H it's always hard to do right so and
the whole point is that it's hard to do
if it was easy to do there wouldn't be
any benefits to it right so um
you know are you stopping because you're
sensitive to an injury or are you
stopping
because pretending that you're being
sensitive to an an injury is an excuse
to
stop this episode is sponsored by kajabi
and they've actually got something
really valuable for all of our Deep dive
listeners now if you haven't heard of
kajabi it's basically a platform that
helps creators diversify their revenue
with courses and membership sites and
communities and podcasts and coaching
tools so it's one of the best places for
creators and entrepreneurs to build a
sustainable business we started using
kajabi earlier this year and as soon as
we started using it we were like oh my
God why haven't we been using this
product for the last 3 years it's got
everything you'd possibly need for
running an online course or hosting an
online community or building an online
coaching business and it essentially
makes it really easy to run your entire
online business from payments to
marketing tools to analytics kajabi has
everything that we creators need all in
one place and actually you don't
necessarily need a huge audience to
generate a sustainable income a Creator
on kajabi can for example make $100,000
by converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying pay them
a couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out
over6 billion doar to creators that's
billion with a be and over a, creators
have become millionaires through
products on the platform now back in May
2023 I did a keynote at a kajabi in real
life kajabi Heroes Event in Austin Texas
and in that keynote I talked about the
exact steps that I used to grow my
business from zero to over $2.5 million
per year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the
kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode hm so I was re rereading um
bertr and Russell's essay In Praise of
idleness um where he's basically talking
about how this you know this attitude
that the modern world inculcates within
us which is that kind of work is
inherently meaningful is like bad and
problematic and all that
jazz I'm like I'm I'm curious for you
like you're presumably planning to write
more books because you're fairly young
in the ground schem of things um but
like why what is the if if if not like I
want to be remembered I want a legacy
then what's what's what's old in service
of no he has a great line he says the
first sign of an impending nervous
collapse is the belief that your work is
terribly terribly important and I think
he's totally right you know if you have
this sense like I'm building this
Monument you know or the world has to
experience my genius uh this is going to
last for a thousand years you know uh
that's not that's not only delusional
but like it's uh kind of a miserable
place to be and it usually end usually
feeds on itself and eventually you know
wears you down um at this point I write
books that I am interested in writing
like that I find myself better for
having
done um this this book that I just did
in the virtu series so I did uh courage
and I did uh discipline and now I'm
doing Justice I'm almost certain this
will be the worst selling book in the
series The Justice one cuz it's the
least you you talked about certain terms
you know will perform good yeah
discipline obviously was I knew if I did
a good job it would be a home run this
one even if I do the greatest job I
possibly can be possibly can do you know
it probably has a ceiling on it in some
way but like I was better for having
done it it I learned something I
articulated something too myself in
writing about it um if my kids are the
only two people that read it you know
like I try to I try to find standards of
success or motivation that have become
more self-sufficient as I've gone y so
at this point I write things
because creatively I find them
interesting and I love the process of
being in the middle of it even
even when it's really hard and I the
same thing is true with running like I
love and I hate running like uh I
obviously not doing it is easier than
doing it but when I don't do it I feel
worse like I feel not in an addictive
way but I feel when I do it I feel proud
of myself I
feel uh physically good I I'm my mind
gets in like it it's better that I do it
than not do it and there the feeling of
being in the middle of a book both
the momentum of it and the frustrating
this of it it all kind of combines into
just an
overall
rewarding immersive experience there's
that's what a flow state is yeah so it
sounds like for you writing is the thing
that your higher self does and wants to
do and therefore is almost uh good in
its in its own right regardless of how
the outcome turns out to be I think so
and so you push yourself to right on
days even when you don't feel like it
it's like going for a run like going to
the gym it's like the thing that you
know is good for you that you know is
aligned with your own personal values
and you don't want to be the sort of guy
that's like you know what I'm going to
skip writing for the next year so I can
play more video games kind of vibe yeah
one of the stoics his name was M ruus he
says when you
do something shameful for pleasure the
pleasure passes quickly but the shame
endures and then he says but when you do
something hard for
good the effort passes quickly but the
good endures oh and I think that's good
you find whether it's pushing yourself
physically like exercise it's throwing
yourself into a big project you know
whether it's sacrificing for someone or
something you
know you quickly forget all that it took
out of you and all that went into it and
you think about the impact that you had
or you just think about the plane you
temporarily ascended to to get there and
then when you think about I don't know
the cake that you ate or you know the
the day that you took or the urge that
you submitted to afterwards there's that
period where you go that's what I did
all that for you know that that that 5
Seconds you know um or not even the 5
Seconds right
and that's the higher lower
self so you've recently done a bit of a
well I wouldn't say pivot like side
hustle on the whole daily dad stuff
which is interesting um a lot of um I've
I I've been just found I found myself
reading a lot of like parenting advice
recently uh I'm not even close to
becoming a bad but I was just curious
and I'm part of your daily newsletter on
on that as well because it's just it's
just interesting but there seems to be
this really common thing of like uh
people working hard uh in their career
sometimes at the expense of their family
mhm um and you know you'll hear people
say that like I thought I was doing my
kids a favor by working and doing this
thing and like focusing on on my career
and stuff but actually what I maybe
should have done in hindsight is to
spend less time on my career and more
time on the kid stuff yeah how do you
think about that balance between like
working hard at the thing but also like
being there for the the small ones well
it's very Insidious cuz you say I'm
doing it all for
them and so you
are doing something very selfish but you
are cloaking it in
selflessness like that's why I'm getting
on this airplane that's why I'm staying
this late at the office that's why I'm
you know blah blah blah blah blah but if
you asked your kids you know what do
they want like more money would be
nowhere in that list right or if if it
if it was on the list it would be such a
preposterously and refreshingly
childlike understanding of money you
know that it would I think it would
humble you so you're you're saying
you're doing it for them but you're not
you're doing it for you you're doing it
for you um um
and the tragedy of
of and the irony of I'm doing it I'm
doing all this for the people I never
see is a very sad [__] up place that a
lot of sort of high power to accomplish
people find themselves in
and I heard something great when someone
said like success is your kids wanting
to be with you when you're an
adult uh and so like how will you
measure your life at the end right um it
won't be like the size of the
inheritance that you leave them it will
be you know are you still in each
other's lives now so how do you invest
in that's not something you can do later
you know what I mean so you have to make
those decisions now and they're and
they're costly and
uncertain and and um the worst part is
you don't even know how much it's
costing I mean this is obviously much
scarier and sort of systemically imposed
on women right so like you're going to
take three years out of your you know
cumulatively three years out of your
working life in your 20s and 30s which
has this enormous cumulative compounding
effect on the trajectory that you're
going to end up uh on you know that's a
very scary thing um and it's it's it's
unfair in a lot of ways um but at the
end of your life you know it's probably
going to be something you're glad that
you did and so I think a lot of men just
sort of unthinkingly don't do it at all
but i' I've tried to sort of go yeah
what is what is it that you want to do
and who do you want to be there's this
great term an art monster I forget this
female writer she was saying like my
dream was to be an art monster basically
just just me and my work and no family
no
you know uh no baggage no impositions
just me and and it there are a lot of
art Monsters and they've written great
stuff but when you read their
biographies you just sort of go H what
you know uh was that worth it you know
um and it kind of It kind of taints all
of the stuff that they did it makes it
much more Bittersweet and not so
great how did you decide to you know go
into the dad stuff rather than quit stay
in your lane as the sto guy I don't know
if I really decided it um I mean so
writing the daily dad I mean the the
reason I decided to do the daily dad was
that writing the daily stoic made me
better as a person you can't every
single day sit down and try to take
insights from the wisest people who ever
lived and distill them down into a
couple hundred words over and over and
over again and not emerge some somewhat
bonded to those idea like it just it
gets in your bloodstream right you're
just that's what stoicism is STO what
marus was doing in his meditations was
writing down things a lot of it comes
from other stoic texts he's just writing
it down rephrasing it and writing it
down and writing it down and rephrasing
it and looking at it this way and
looking he's having this philosophical
discussion with with himself and that's
how Marcus realist becomes Markus
realist so the process of writing the
daily stoic book and then writing the
daily sto every day now for seven years
it's almost a million words that I
published for free uh to you know I
think we've done 3,000 daily sto emails
it's like seven or eight books worth of
content um I have benefited from that
like it's built a business around it but
like if I had made precisely zero dollar
that would have been the bargain of a
Lifetime right like I've gotten so much
better from having done that and so I
just decided that I would do the same
thing about parenting and if it helps
other people great you know um if it
sells books great but the process of
having to intentionally sit down and
think about and then write about and
then publish you know how I want to
think about these things has made me
better H and that's how that's how you
should think about it I was I was
talking to my wife last night we were
talking about this
um book that we were reading and um you
know you get all the way to the end
you're like oh that was good but
actually you needed in you needed to
read it over like six months like a
couple Pages a day like um I just read
this great book by this parenting expert
name is Dr Becky Kennedy um and so I
read it but then because I'm going to
write about it for daily Deb I went
through it Page by Page after and took
out all the stuff that I liked um and it
was the second part was where I got
stuff out of it not the reading at once
from cover to cover and so there's
something about the page a day format
that's worked in Daily stoic and daily
dad like if you're trying to absorb a
philosophy or a new way of thinking or
transform yourself from here to there
it's it's not 300 pages that you read
you know from October 1st to November
17th you know it takes you a month and a
half to read it's much better if you're
layering it like a page a day for a year
or two years or 3 years and you're
coming back like the process of that
sort of over and over and over and over
again that's that's where the stuff gets
absorbed what is some of the key um I
guess you know from from here to there
like through the course of writing daily
D and kind of being a parent what is
what are some of the key lessons that
have really sort of separated the Ryan
today from the r maybe like three years
ago um um I think
patience I think like if I'm thinking
like the the things I've struggled with
most as a parent but that have also made
the most
difference uh number one like the
greatest thing you can give your gift
your your your kids is presents like not
gifts but presence like just actually
being there not doing something else so
you know in a digital world that's
extremely difficult to do um so I
struggled that patience of course um you
know it doesn't happen it doesn't have
to happen quickly it just has to happen
um to take your time with it to let them
take their time to not rush things um
every time you think you can't go on
like this that's when you get some sort
of breakthrough every time you think
they're never going to figure it out
that's when they figure it out so I
think patience has been a big one
um i' I've read a lot and thought about
like sort of how do you just like just
root for this person like not not attach
any conditions not attach any judgments
not attach any expectations but just be
an unconditional supporter of them and
who they are for who they are and what
they are um which I think ties into
another idea I've been thinking a lot
about which is like your job is to help
your kids become that person not to make
them a person that you want them to be
you know so to just sort of help them
become who they are that's something
I've thought a lot about and worked on a
lot
um and then the one I've been thinking a
lot about which I heard about in Dr
Becky's book obviously I knew about it
but it made sense she talks about like
don't try to be a perfect parent try to
be a parent who's really good at repair
like at fixing it when you mess up
fixing it when things didn't go the way
that you wanted them to go you know
reconnecting when you know there is
conflict or when people go in separate
directions but but repair so I would say
those are those are sort of The
Perennial ones that I struggle with and
I'm thinking about that's really cool
yeah I I um you know my YouTube channel
is is essentially an exploration of the
stuff I'm interested in and I've
recently started to become interested in
uh relationships in terms of reading
books about how to have a healthier
happier relationship uh and I I hope
that when I become a dad and continue
making videos then I'll be like yeah
reading all these parenting books and
like making a video every every couple
of months to be like right I've just
read this sick unconditional parenting
Alfie go good good [__] 10 10 takeaways
that sort of stuff I found I guess
similar to you kind of writing daily
stoic through me trying to make a video
or two every week for six plus years all
personal development adjacent those
lessons seep into your subconscious in a
way that like they really wouldn't
otherwise yeah yeah Senus is we learn as
we teach and so if you as a person who
writes self-help books or makes YouTube
videos or as a poast or whatever if
you're thinking I'm really smart and I
am telling you everything that I
know not only is that egotistical but it
actually continues to inflate and uh
puff up the EGO right but if instead you
see it as like I am trying to figure
things out and I am explaining what I am
learning as I am learning it yeah you
are learning it and other people are
learning it and you're creating this
feedback loop in which you're both
learning at the same time
and by having to articulate it and
explain it and distill it you are
understanding it better than if you were
just learning it for yourself yeah yeah
there's a book I'm reading at the moment
called uh notes from a fellow traveler
by Darren Brown he's a magician yeah
yeah he's really into STM oh he's he is
his book happy is very good basically
all about stoicism um but I really like
the title of that book notes from a
fellow traveler he's he sort of a book
written for other magicians um but that
framing like a fellow traveler I really
like that cuz he's not trying to be a
guru he he's not saying I've got the
answers he's just like hey I'm in this
business just as you are and here are
some notes MH and I just love that
framing of it it just takes takes all
the pressure off reduces the seriousness
makes it feel more like play all all the
good things yeah someone who's just a
little bit further along the path in
some ways or struggling with their own
things and you're and you're sort of
channeling that and trying to make
it accessible and
practical to other people what is what
are some like I I really like this list
of the the parenting some things do you
have any
on relationships in general
like uh like the Romantic relationship
with your wife and things what are some
things that you guys do that maybe
you've discovered through Reading and
stuff that well I always say that the
number one SE so I've been with my wife
now for 17 years we we met when we were
in
college and um we uh we met at a college
party we got married almost 10 years ago
I think 8 years this year 9 years so
it's been a long time so it's and we
basically been married that whole time
uh in that we always had a a very sort
of
involved like serious relationship as
opposed to just we known each other a
long time um and so people sometimes ask
what the secret to like you know lasting
that long is and I usually say that the
the secret is to not break up that's the
secret that's the number one secret is
to just not break up um because I'm
joking but I'm also not joking right
like I
think just as a productivity system or a
business or a lifesty what it's about
picking a thing and then sticking with
that thing right um through the ups and
downs
of what life inevitably brings you and I
find you know obviously we got together
before online dating was really even a
thing but then dating apps and like I
notice that a lot of my friends struggle
because it's easy to break up and it's
easy to find another person do you know
what I mean like essentially an
unlimited amount of other fish in the
sea exist and if you conceive of that it
makes it very hard to
do what a relationship requires you know
what I mean which is sacrifice which is
struggle which is putting up with [__]
you know so it's heart it's like it's
really heart it's heart uh so I I uh
profess to have no no secrets other than
don't quit I mean it's it's amazing how
in in all these different spheres like
you know the stuff you were talking
about with the kids presence patience
rooting without conditions judgments
expectations being repair not being
perfect all of that stuff applies
to every other aspect of life as well
like work too well even the kid Stu
applies to self right because we all
have sort of we all have this inner
child that needs work right that's stuck
somewhere not fully developed and one of
the beautiful things about having kids
is the way that
it allows you to reparent yourself
because you
suddenly fully understand what a
six-year-old is going through or a
nine-year-old is going through or a
9-month-old is going through and you can
see more clearly now the things that you
didn't get that maybe you needed um
or the ways
that how everyone used to do things was
insufficient um maybe just for you
specifically or maybe just as a practice
it was terrible and you can kind of see
oh okay I can't go back in time and fix
that but I can do things differently
here and I can also empathize connect
with an earlier version of myself that
needed those things too and that by
giving that thing to someone else you're
also partly healing
yourself that's great stuff um you're in
pretty good shape what are some of the
secrets to stay staying in good shape as
you've you know been a parent I possess
to have profess to Have No Secrets there
either other than I try to run swim or
bike every day I just try to do some
hard
strenuous physical activity every
day um
and if there is a health benefit to
that I consider it a bonus on top of
the two real benefits that having an
exercise practice gives you one you are
literally practicing having a practice
like every day I go for a run the
default is that I do the thing and every
time I do the thing I'm building the
muscle of doing the thing and being the
kind of person that does what I I say
I'm going to do yeah like it's not fun
to do it it can hurt to do it but I get
up off the couch and I do the thing that
I say I'm going to do and the second
benefit of having the physical practice
is
that
it's
usually getting the mind moving in some
way uh and so you know there's no
screens there's
no multitasking you're just in that head
space so like I have the I have the the
flow state every day from the physical
activity
and the days when I don't have it
nothing else is as works as
well do you do any weight training or
yeah I try to lift weights like I don't
know a couple times a week feel like
I've seen some b-roll of you in like the
backyard yeah I like kettle bells or I
have like a squat rack like I do some
stuff not as in the pandemic I got more
into it than I do
now the important thing for me is I run
swim or bike like that I do some form of
cardio exercise for a long period of
time and then if I can get the other
stuff in
sure changing gears a bit um I was Rel
listening to the conversation we had
three years ago in the car on the way
here um and the one of the things you
said in that has actually stayed with me
for the last three years it was
something to the effect of you know
you've got all these who are in real
estate and sometimes you're like huh
maybe I should get into real estate and
then you realize all your friends want
to be self-help book writers and you're
like huh I've got a pretty good gig I
wonder if you can just sort of like Riff
on that for for a sec senica had this
word emia which he defines as
Tranquility it says Tranquility is the
sense of the path that you were on and
not
being distracted by the paths that
crisscross yours he says especially from
those who are hopeless lost which I
think is very
beautiful and
[Music]
true sometimes you find like when you're
running you know someone will pass you
and you go are they faster than me they
could have started 8 seconds ago and you
could be five miles in or they could
be stronger than you they could be doing
steroid you know like there's un the
idea that you're comparing yourself to
this person when you don't know when
they started and you don't where they're
finished finishing is madness right um
and life is like that like we're all
running our own races and you got to
have a sense of the race that you are
running and what victory or success in
that race is to you so I think that's
like just the number one life lesson and
something I I remember learning run
around this track in college and I would
sometimes catch myself picking up my
Pace to keep up with someone else and
then they would stop and I'm like I just
gassed
myself
you know now I have to cut the Run short
because I was competing with this person
and I have no idea what their goals are
what they're doing I I know nothing
about them other than someone
competition you know and it it sucks you
in so I think that's a really important
lesson that I've learned from the
physical practice over the years
but one of the things about jealousy or
sort envy that sort of competitive urge
that we feel in other parts of Our Lives
is that we don't spend a lot of time
thinking about who that other person is
what their life is
like uh and what they want you know
Marcus really says like these the people
whose approval you you crave he says
take a minute to think about who they
really are and whether and see what that
does to the approval you want from them
right it's like you just go oh this
person has this I want to be like them
or I want to to be accepted into that
group I want to be in this club and
you're not really thinking about who
those people are what they do whether
it's working for them and I've had this
surreal sort of experience pertaining to
that where you
meet people and you think they have it
all and then you know you're jealous of
them and then it turns out they're
jealous of you right like you
you jealousy almost always takes for
granted what you have cuz it's you know
eyeing what someone else has and there's
usually a an ignorance of would you act
what what is it actually like to be that
other person and i' yeah I found it's
funny you meet and meet these
billionaires or whatever and what do
they actually want to do they want to
write books like they they have all the
money in the world and what are they
trying to spend the money on they're
trying to spend it on having the thing
that I get to do and so I I try to
remind myself of that and count myself
as lucky to get to do this do you feel
that sense of comparison or or do you
slid you ever feel that sense of
comparison when it comes to uh
bestseller lists and book sales numbers
and H James clear's got this many five
star reviews on Amazon and I've only got
this many you know that that whole
shebang well that's why it's important
to understand what race you're running
right so um I remember I was at a
conference
in Canada I don't remember I was at some
conference in James who was uh then he
had this popular newsletter and I S
vaguely knew his work we talked a couple
times I was doing a panel or session on
publishing and he came and he asked for
a bunch of advice but he was just
generally if I remember correctly quite
skeptical about why anyone would
traditionally publish or publish a book
at all he's like why would I do this I
have this huge email newsletter why
wouldn't I just write stuff on the
internet and I thought I said look
people have read books for thousands
thousand of years it's a it's a medium
that has a certain cultural significance
and books are actually a great way to
deliver ideas right but there I was a
person who' published you know a few
successful books at that point and I'm
sort of like condescendingly telling
this internet writer why publishing
should uh you know be something that he
considers and then a couple years later
he puts out a book and that one book has
sold more than all of my books combined
and then some
so you
know the one reaction to that would just
be jealousy scorn s like you could you
that could make you feel shitty and I
think there are times in my life when
maybe that would have made me feel
shitty but first off I like James second
I think he's a great writer and I think
Atomic abits is actually a very good
book and third I don't know how many I'm
counting now but whatever there is no
Universe in which that book selling more
or less copies affects my life in any
negative or positive way right like so
that book could sell a 100 million
copies they're not it's not coming out
of my pocket right so more power to them
right um and so I've tried to remind
myself of that but then what I you have
to do when you realize you're running
your own race is you have to go James is
writing a book about habits which is for
everyone I am writing about an obscure
School of ancient philosophy which I
would like to be for everyone but by
definition is probably going to be for
fewer people and that is a choice that I
made
willingly I can write about whatever I
want I could have written about whatever
I want I chose this thing or this thing
chose me because it's the right thing
for me and you have to be able to go ah
right this is where I'm supposed to be I
made a series of choices and For Better
or For Worse those choices made some
outcomes possible and some outcomes not
possible like I remember I spoke to
these uh high ranking officers in the
Navy once a couple years ago and I was
talking about ego or something and I
said you know like if you got into this
for like money and recognition and fame
you [__] up like you shouldn't have
joined the Navy like you joined this
because there were certain parts of it
that Lit you up that were meaningful to
you you that you thought were the right
fit for
you you chose classical music not pop
music right and by nature of making that
choice some outcomes are possible and
some outcomes are not possible and you
have to accept that and the worst thing
you can do is make those choices which
are objective
and sort of
unbeatable and then work really hard and
expect things that
are in contradiction of that choice do
you know what I mean like if you're a
classical musician and you go my goal is
to be the best classical musician I can
be and to push the boundaries of blah
blah blah blah blah then you can succeed
if you go I'm putting out this album and
I hope it debuts at number one on the
billboard charts you know you're almost
surely going to be severely disappointed
because you've chosen something that is
a smaller pool
you know maybe you have a higher flooor
but a lower ceiling that's the nature of
the choice that you made and being
honest with yourself about that is
really really important at least for
happiness yeah do you ever meet writers
who you feel have sort of this unhealthy
relationship with comparison is like or
most of the people you just hang out
with fairly enlightened no no I mean
definitely there's people that are you
know sort of driven by how much they
sell or how much money they make or
whatever but
again if that's why you got into books
you [__] up you know what I mean like
if you got into writing books for money
and fame and power you're an idiot like
like
there's that's not even that's
like that's probably the
worst of all the different genres of
entertainment or Show Business yeah you
pick the worst one like for that if
that's what you're optimizing for you
pick the worst one um
so to expect like the sto say don't
expect figs in Winter that's like the
essence of happiness is to not expect
figs in Winter there's a time when you
can get figs and it's not winter um so
you know you can be successful writing
books you can
make uh a good amount of money you can
make more money than you need but are
you going to rival the fortune of Warren
Buffett no you know so to expect
otherwise is probably silly it's not
even probably silly it's stupid it's
stupid and it's not fair it's not fair
to you or to the people around you right
because you are feeling
grieved that you didn't get something
that it was not possible ever to get so
my book is coming out in at the end of
December so I'm not sure when this is
going to be aired but end of December uh
any advice it's the first one um you've
been been through this a lot yeah um so
I always tell people when they finish a
book yeah that you have completed the
first of two
marathons and you you finish this first
marathon and you think and you're like
you stagger across the finish line and
and you think they're someone grabs you
by the hand and you think that they're
going to take you over to like the metal
stand and instead they're just leading
you over to the starting line of the
second Marathon which is now marketing
and selling the book MH talking about it
and getting it into people's hands yeah
and so understanding that these are two
equally important
races um I think is really really
important and not enough people do that
they just write something and they just
expect or assume that the world owes
them success which it doesn't people are
busy people have a lot going on there's
not only all the books that are coming
out but there's literally everything
that has ever been published for all of
human history up until this point and a
lot of it is very good and most people
haven't even gotten into a fraction of
that so the idea that your thing is
going to jump in front of that line is
inherently presumptuous if not
delusional and so it takes a lot of work
to break through you know the obstacles
the way when it came out first off I
said to
myself I'm writing a book about anci
philosophy and most people are not
interested in ancient philosophy yeah so
it's already an uphill battle and then I
said to myself I read a lot how many
books do I read the week they come out
or the month they come out or the year
they come out and I read way more than
most
people how many books have I pre-ordered
ever in my life maybe one or two so the
idea that this thing is going to come
out of the gate as a
hit is stupid you know it's going to
take a long time so first off you try to
make something that doesn't
need doesn't have an expiration date on
it that's number one number two seeing
it as a marathon and not a Sprint is
really really important so the obstacles
the way came out in May
of
2014 I had started writing it in 2012 so
it took two years came out
it
sold three 4,000 copies its first
week it got skunked on the New York
Times bestseller
list skunked yeah like it should it
probably sold enough to hit the what was
then the extended list there was 20
spots on the advice how to then and it
didn't and it certainly sold enough to
hit the Wall Street Journal hard cover
business list and uh someone at my
publisher had decided to list it as a
like a different like it didn't qualify
for that list like they categorized they
checked the Box cized something
different didn't hit it yeah so it did
not hit any bestseller list
until September of 2019 wow nice at
which point it had sold close to a
million
copies um so again we think like you
know we think of what a bestseller is we
we forget that bestseller lists are
categorized by the week so a book that
sells 10,000 copies in one week will hit
a bestseller list for that week almost
certainly but a book that sells 1,000
copies a week for a year sell five times
as many copies but almost certainly not
make any bestseller list and which would
you rather have um and
so it's about setting yourself up to
last
and it's about not quitting on it nice
um and the obstacles way sells most
years sells more copies than it did the
previous year which is you know pretty
rare in publishing but every single week
that comes out it that it is
out how many copies it's sold in its
first week becomes less and less
important right and yeah unless you are
not
successful that will be true for your
project
right like every week the percentage of
how you did at the beginning becomes
more and more meaningless becomes more
and more
meaningless but that's very hard to
think about when you when it is 100% of
the weeks that you have been out right
um takes time and and realizing that
when the thing I've try tried to say to
myself is
um the to people who have never heard of
you you are new so I I'll prob almost
certainly have an in email in my inbox
when I get done from this from someone
that say I just read your book the
obstacles away that is approaching its
10 year anniversary yeah right and so to
them it's a brand new book and it's a
brand new book to them because they're a
junior in high school yeah you know and
they were eight when it came out you
know um and so you know that's what sort
of lasting can do
um and to and to yeah to to sort of be
be patient with is the main the main
thing we so we we have a telegram group
for our podcast and we said we were
going to to interview you and we had
loads of people asking loads of
questions there's one comment from one
guy that I felt a bit salty about he was
like Ryan holiday says the same stuff on
every podcast he's interviewed on and I
was like H cuz I also I I say the same
stuff on every podcast I interview and
it's like it's kind kind of like a thing
you have to do and like I I found that
it was it was less a common in you and
more like I started thinking [__] you
know I've made the same video so many
times I've talk been talking about
productivity for like six plus years now
I've basically been saying the same
stuff but each each month we get like
100,000 new subscribers it's clearly new
to someone yeah there's some main
character energy in in people who don't
realize that um yeah most people are
consuming this thing for the first time
and hearing about this person for the
first time M so you know a as a Creator
there's a little bit of narcissism in
that you go like everyone's following
everything that I do and in fact not
only is most people not know that you
exist even the people that know you
exist and are fans you're like 500th on
their list of priorities like I think
about my favorite bands my favorite
authors like how closely am I following
their life like not at all yeah I'm I
main character energy my own life so
realizing that like that
self-consciousness can actually hold you
back as a Creator cuz you're like
they'll people will get mad that I just
talked about this two videos ago and
actually they didn't see two videos ago
so you're not but um the other product
of this is is the other part I would say
to that person that's a little tricky is
it's like dude it's not my fault like I
can only answer the questions that I'm
being asked and I tend to get asked the
same questions right what is so so so
like I would love to be I would love to
have a totally new and unique
conversation every time and I do I I
definitely feel like there are ones
where I'm going that that was
interesting to me for a change I didn't
feel like I was sort of you know uh
giving the same song and dance but a lot
of people are just asking the same
questions because they're introducing
you to Their audience or they want to
get the the basics you know what I mean
so it's it can be weird do you ever good
get boarded writing about
stoicism um not really uh
because one of the ideas from the Greeks
is this idea that we don't step in the
same river twice because the river
changes and you change and so I
mean I've been doing the daily stoky
maill every day for seven years
and I've
probably used some of the same quotes
hundreds of times at this point but it
feels new to me every time I do it
because what I'm trying to say or the
way into the idea is different and I
know the audience is different and I
know what's happening in the world is
different so it it keeps it it certainly
keeps me it feels fresh to me because
life is fresh um
but when I am bored I just write about
whatever I want you know like it isn't
the only thing that I do uh and so when
I feel like writing something I write
that thing H yeah cuz people sometimes
ask me that you know are you Bor aren't
you bored of talking about productivity
like honestly not really like I'm bored
of I guess making videos that are like
top 10 productivity tools but I do very
little of that these days and I think
productivity is you know really just
about using our time well which covers
basically everything in personal
development and so even if I'm writing
about relationships or making a video
about
health I would count that as
productivity yeah but but also you know
productivity to you when you were in
medical school is different than what
productivity is to you now as you are
not in medicine it's different to you
when you had one employee it's different
to you when you had 10 you know it what
you're going through and where you're
applying it is fundamentally different
so even if you're talking about the same
ideas you have a larger sense of it you
have a larger set of experiences to draw
from and so even if it is the same it's
it's better and different yeah because
it's based on
more nice why do you think people are so
interested in passive
income oh I'm really interested in
passive income does it exist I I think
it does um so there's this the this
whole dream I I'm I'm not sure if if Tim
Ferris used the phrase in four hour work
week or if it was a thing afterwards but
I remember reading that book when I was
like 17 and just about about to yeah and
just like just about to apply to medical
school and my mind just absolutely blew
wide open at the the thought that I
could be making money while I slept and
just that thing of like you know was
always always in the back of my mind and
now we know it's it's another one of
those things that anytime we make a
video on YouTube uh with the with the
phrase passive income in it we know it's
going to do well cuz people love the
idea
of of doing a thing and then it making
money without needing your additional
input I think kind of like books books
are a source of passive income yeah well
intellectual property exactly yeah you
know you wrote the obstacles away 10
years ago and it's now been making you
passive income ever since um I've
certainly found in our business um the
stuff that I I I get so much
satisfaction out of seeing like a a
stripe notification that someone bought
a course I filmed three years ago and
I've made $149 from it and way less
satisfaction making way more money on a
sponsored video because there's
something about it being an asset that
is spinning off I guess free money that
is like really nice and also I guess it
really appeals to other people yeah I
guess that makes sense I was talking to
an internet marketer person that I knew
and you know like let's say he was
saying like the email subject line like
follow a strategy to make $1,000 a month
or to make thousands of dollars a month
would actually perform worse than say
like this strategy helps me make
$1,447 per month like the spe he was
saying like the specificity of it
if
ital
people and I alwaysed
what there's
something naive is not the wrong right
word maybe unsophisticated is a nicer
way to say that about the idea that you
if you just do all this stuff at some
point you won't have to do anything do
you know what I mean because that's not
really how life Works in my experience
yeah no it's not really how life Works
um nor is it how you would actually nor
is it how the life works for most of the
people that you admire do you know what
I mean yeah like people who do stuff
that you're like that's cool I want to
be like that are not people who
own a series of vending machines that
passively make money while they sleep do
you know what I mean they're people who
are actively engaged in what they do
yeah I guess um I
so I've I've I've kind of gone back and
forth on this whole passive income thing
um we we still make videos about passive
income and I always do a whole like 20
minutes of philosophizing at the start
to be like okay here's how money Works
money is an exchange of value blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah um but I
find that like if I think back to myself
back when I was in medical school the
thought of being able to if I if someone
gave me a vending machine business and
it was making 3,000 a month I'm like
whoa I never need to work a day in my
life now now I can now I can do what I
really want to do sure and just that Co
being able to cover the basics through
some sort of automated income stream
even if it's not like greatness or
anything even if it's just like I don't
know automated vending machine selling
Coke cans or like a t-shirt business or
whatever the thing
is I think that is that that is still
very appealing because then it's like
cool the bases are now covered I can now
spend my time doing the things that I I
actually want to do I get that yeah I I
I I thought about I thought it about it
that way earlier in my career I mean for
if I had a job as I was becoming a
writer which allowed me to make certain
creative decisions that maybe if I was a
starving artist I wouldn't have been
able I wouldn't have had the luxury of
being able to turn things down or doing
things a certain way or having as much
time but then yeah I thought I it was
like I don't have a trust fund but if I
have sort of income streams other than
like the creative work that I do it's
like I gave myself a trust fund yeah and
now I have a certain amount of
Freedom or
Independence that I wouldn't if I was
living and dying by how single paycheck
yes or or till I burned through the book
Advance or whatever it was you honestly
like there and anytime I make one of
these money themed videos there are
always some comments that say oh I can't
believe you're so obsessed with money
like stop talking about money all the
time I'm like oh this guy is such a so
greedy and and stuff but I'm always like
no like having having more than on
stream of income is genuinely
life-changing like the fact that I had
money coming in from my YouTube channel
and my business meant that I could leave
my day job or at least go part-time on
it to focus on the thing that actually
brought me joy and fulfillment being
able to have an extra stream of income
is what allows parents to spend more
time with their kids sure it's like one
of the most worthwhile things in the
world to have if you care about personal
freedom and fulfillment and stuff um and
so I was sort of feel I feel a bit dist
of of the phrase passive income but I
almost view it as a bit of a a troan
horse into kind of teaching people that
like hey you know the way you actually
make money is by creating x amount of
value and capturing y% of it now just
figure out a way that you can do that
that's not correlated with your time
generally by creating something that's
like Media or code or basically those
two things yeah or Investments or or
yeah or money itself yeah yeah uh yeah
people talk about like you know I want
to earn like [__] you money but really
you could just have enough to be like eh
you know or like I don't need to yeah or
you know just just enough that it can it
can kind of help you swing you one way
or another as you're thinking about
making a decision do you know what I
mean uh whereas if your livelihood is
dependent on this thing entirely it's
very hard to I think about like I mean
obviously you're not American but in in
America the fact that for most people
their health insurance is tied up yeah
it's the D it's especially as a country
that celebrates entrepreneurialism and
risk-taking it seems like the most basic
thing in the world that you would want
to separate those two things so people
could take bigger risks and bet on
themselves and do like you shouldn't
think I could literally die if I leave
my job that's Madness to me
but being able to go hey actually I'm
going to I'm going to
it's I'm going to see where this thing
takes me and I know I'm not going to
starve like I know that I have this
thing maybe it's not covering my full
expenses like you know what I mean like
I I have these things that allow me like
when I when I did the obstacles the way
my publisher offered me about half of
what I'd gotten paid for my first book
so if I didn't have my day job um I
probably I don't know if I would have
said yes um but I I wasn't indifferent
to money but I was able to go I really
don't care what the amount is what I
care about is are you going to publish
this
book because if you are then I'm going
to go all in on this thing do you know
what I mean and and so having I I do see
how that gives you gives you a certain
amount of freedom of
movement yeah I think like even like
even in the UK so obviously like Health
in your health insurance is not tied to
your employment and the National Health
Service is very good but even then
people
still act as if quitting their job means
that they're going to die yes and I'll
often speak to people who you know like
you know back in the day I was a bit
concerned that oh if I leave medicine
will people think oh [__] you I don't
want to listen to your content anymore
uh but it's actually kind of the
Opposites happened people are like oh
man you got out of the system you like I
don't know something about the Matrix
and stuff so people keep ask ask ask me
for advice around quitting their job all
the time they're like yeah I really want
to leave my job and do this thing I'm
like great what's stopping you they're
like oh but like you know the paycheck
and I'm like okay are you on the poverty
line where like this paycheck is
actually meaningful there is a
difference between survival and not
they're like nope have you got any
dependence nope these are all people in
their 20s that have a safety net from
their parents and yet still the thought
I might quote fall behind yeah and like
fall behind my friends who are then
getting that promotion at Mackenzie or
whatever the thing might be is
preventing people from making a decision
they just very unlikely to regret so I
try and like nudge that as much as
possible well I I got so lucky when I
dropped out of college since
I've talked about this before but when I
went in there I was like I'm here to
drop out of college and they were like
what you know uh they're like just fill
out this form you take out you're you're
just taking an indefinite leave of
absence you can come back whenever you
want there were some consequences like I
I remember I was
signing I signed something and it was
like your scholarship may not be here
when you're back as an adult now I
realize they probably just would have
given it to me again but like so there
it wasn't totally without cost but there
was the idea
that like I thought it was this
permanent
irrevocable lifestyle decision when in
fact it was a pause and you think hey
I'm going to leave this to go do this
I'm going to go give this a try I'm
going to open this coffee shop you think
you can never go back yeah and of course
you can go back if you were in the
hospital for a year would you be sitting
there going I can never go back to my
job no you would
know there's going to it's going to be
an adjustment period I might have some
ketchup I have to you know there's but
you you just go get another job like
that's how life works right and but
especially when you're younger and you
don't have the experience it feels like
the shift or the transition or the the
quitting can never be
undone and only the time you realize
that the stakes were so much lower than
you thought they were yeah yeah I find
the the Tim FIS fear setting exercise to
be just really helpful actually the
worst case scenario what's the worst
case it's like okay what does it look
like how could you me to get against it
let's say the worst case does happen
what can you do to come back to where
you currently are or at least some place
that's good enough um I think I've done
that like three or four times in my life
had the sort of Crux of making a big
decision and I've always been like oh
this is really helpful yeah the worst
case is never as bad as we think it is
and recovering from the worst case is
also never as hard as we initially think
it's going to be yeah I remember when I
was thinking of dropping out I was
talking to this person and and who was
telling me I should do it and I go you
know what happens if it doesn't work out
you know and he he was like when I was
in college he's like I got mono or
something he had he got some and he he
spent a year recovering yeah and he's
like do you know how many times this has
come up in my life that it took me five
years to graduate from college zero
times nobody knows nobody even does the
math you started college at this date
you got your first like nobody knows it
just it as more time goes by it just all
go like you spent your time in college
now you're not in college no one's like
oh but
what about that year between your
sophomore and your junior year what was
that about it it never comes up and his
point was like if I take this risk and
it doesn't work out I just go back and
it takes you four years to graduate five
years whatever it's it's a it's a
rounding error in the big scheme of
things there a good I think it's the
thing that Jeff Bezos says um which is
like you know he's he's talking about
kind of the game of Entrepreneurship and
he's sort of likening it to a baseball
match and he's like normally in a
baseball match you can either hit one to
four runs or whatever the number is I
don't know anything about baseball but
he's like in entrepreneurship you can
take a swing but like the upside of the
Swing is infinite yes and so if you take
enough swings you can actually get an
outcome that way outperforms what you
could have done if you were doing the
job thing sure for example um and I
think the you know I I I wish more
people would appreciate the asymmetry of
The Upside that you get from taking a
risk and doing your own thing
potentially right so you you you
understand and you articulate the
downside Which is less than you think
and then it's hard to wrap your head
around the fact that the upside could
literally be incom comprehensible like
when Jeff Bezos starts Amazon he has
some idea that it could be successful
but it would have been literally
impossible to conceive of what it became
yeah because it didn't exist yet and
when I left I had this sense that I
wanted to be a writer and I knew that I
thought leaving got me closer a better
chance of being that writer than staying
and maybe it's true maybe it's not but
like
the the writing that I ended up doing
and the level at which I ended up doing
it would have been if I thought that's
what I was doing I should have been
certified you know what I mean like I
would have been a sign of a mental
illness like there any sense that this
is how it was going to go yeah you know
what I mean so you're just taking it
step by step yeah I think the the other
big thing that I found really helpful
was you know back in Jeff's day we where
there were very few examples of what
does entrepreneurship look like like
these days no one like people don't have
that excuse anymore like if someone want
is even entertaining the thought of
being a writer there are a zillion
interviews with professional writers out
there if someone wants to be an
entrepreneur there are a zillion
interviews with entrepreneurs where
they're literally talking about how much
money they're making yeah similarly for
YouTube and stuff um and so
so surrounding I think an information
diet is a really important part of this
like even just watching videos reading
books and listening to podcasts from
people who are doing the thing that you
think you want to do helps you realize
that oh are fair Fairly normal they've
just been doing it for a while and oh
that's what the outcome could look like
yeah like look if you're no one no one
goes must be impossible to be an
accountant how does someone become an
accountant right because you accountants
are everywhere right although you know
if you grew up in the inner city and
you're
parents didn't work and you never had it
might actually seem utterly unattainable
and impossible to become that thing and
the reality is it's not people do it
every [__] day and that's not to say
it's easy but it is possible it's very
possible and if you steep yourself in
how possible it is and surround yourself
not physically but intellectually with
people who have done it you figure out
how it can be done and you we talk a lot
these days about like nepo babies and
nepotism I think so much of that is if
your mom was a famous actress sure that
gives you advantages and introductions
and you're in this sort of millu that's
beneficial but also that doesn't
seem impossible or impractical cuz your
mom is doing it she's not that great do
you know what I mean she's like you know
you're just like people do this it is a
job you see how it works it's
deconstructed and mystified for you in a
way
that allows you to go to give yourself
that self- assignment like I could do
that yeah it was the same for me with
the medicine stuff like I didn't have
any in any official Advantage getting
into medic school but my both my parents
are doctors all of my friends's parents
are doctors basically everyone I knew
growing up was a doctor and so like it
doesn't seem that hard people become
doctors people become doctors and then
you know it was only when I started
applying to med school and stuff where
some people oh my oh my God you're
applying to me wow that's so hard is I
is it like everyone I know is a doctor
like it's not that big a deal um I think
it's that same concept applied to yeah
anything so people will probably be
listening to this towards the end of the
year where they start thinking of habits
and resolutions if someone's like I want
to be more
productive next year yeah what would you
tell them oh if someone wants to be more
productive next year
all right I've got got three three
things number one is actually just
figure out or at least make a rough
first draft of where do you actually
want to go like sure you can be more
productive by cranking out more words
per day or whatever but like if you're
not trying to be a writer and don't have
a vague sense of what productivity is
not a goal exactly yes productivity is
like uh sort of an Effectiveness
measurement on route to a particular
goal and if you don't have that goal
then optimizing for productivity
is completely pointless yeah so I think
step one is to figure out what the goal
is you know some people don't like the
word goal um the the most helpful
exercise i' I've ever found for this is
uh something called The Odyssey plan
from the book designing your life by
Bill Bernett is and this other guy who's
like some Stanford professors uh and
basically the idea is that you imagine
your life three to five years in the
future if you continue to down your
current path and you write out what it
would look like then you go back back to
day one back to today and and you
imagine your life 3 to 5 years from now
if you had to take a completely
different path and then you go back and
then you imagine your life 3 to 5 years
from now if you had to take a completely
different path but Money Was No Object
and you didn't care about what people
thought of you and that just gives you
sort of this Divergent thinking that
most people just never do and I I
personally enjoy like doing that
exercise every year and then converting
it into a okay what does my 12- month
celebration look like 12 months from now
what would I like to be celebrating in
the different Realms of Life Health work
relationships Joy those are the four
that I like personally sure and now I've
got some goals written down and there's
so much evidence that says that people
who write down goals people who have
goals are way more productive than
people who don't and people who write
them down are even way more productive
than people who don't write them down so
step one figure out what your goals are
and just write them down step two I find
it super helpful to just convert all of
those goals into what is the action I
have to take each week so so if you're
for example trying to write a book it
might be a daily action of writing for 2
hours a day or a thousand words or
whatever the thing might be in my case
I'm trying to get fit and so weight
training three times three times a week
is the habit or the system I'm trying to
develop um and then number three is
putting all those things in the calendar
oh and then if they're in the calendar
and you can turn and you can make
yourself the sort of person that does
what's in the calendar honestly that is
like 95% of all of all of the world's
productivity advice condensed into three
things figure out where you want to go
turn it into and figure out how you're
going to get there and then just put it
in the calendar and do the thing when it
comes around with a fresh year coming
what would you recommend people stop
doing like what's a what's like a a
destructive habit that you would say to
get rid
of a really big
one that holds everyone back is
overthinking um so much research from
this book around procrastination was
realizing that procrastination is
primarily an emotional problem um there
is some sort of kind of fear of looking
bad fear of failure self-doubt uh the
mind starts to weave all these stories
about how we're not good enough to do
this particular thing and you know I've
interviewed a couple of kind of procrast
professors in procrastination who've
done all the research about this and
their their whole thing is like you've
just got to find a way to cut through
the [__] that the mind will present
present to you and just make a start on
the thing and often procrastination is a
problem with getting started because
once we get started the means that we'll
just continue going it's way harder to
objects in motion tend to continue
exactly new's first law yeah we talk
about that in chapter four of the book
um so recognizing that has has really
helped me recognize that when the mind
is getting in the way the best thing I
can do is just get started with the
thing and then the mind has a habit of
just sort of getting out of the way but
if people can stop overthinking and stop
letting this fear of self-doubt and
failure and stuff get in the way getting
in the way of living their best life I
would love that I would love for that to
happen all right last question what's
something you feel like the stoics can
teach a person who wants Feelgood
productivity yeah I think the the main
one I always come back to is the
dichotomy of control um epic teas is it
yeah um you know there are some things
that are within our control and there
are other things that are not within our
control and any amount of worrying about
the things that are not within our
control is usually worry that it's
wasted and I think a big part of
feel-good productivity is find a way to
control the things that you can control
you know a huge part of what drives
intrinsic motivation is the sense of
autonomy sense of control the sense that
we have power over what we're doing and
some people are like well you know I
don't have any control over what my boss
tells me to do I like okay you might not
have control over the specific thing you
have to do but you might have control
over how you choose to approach it you
have control over the process can you
find a way to make it more interesting
can you find a way to speed it up can
you find a way to slow it down can you
find a way to I don't know add music in
the background to make it more
interesting there is always control that
we can take in basically every situation
even in situations where we feel like we
have none and there's that quote from
Victor Frankl where he's you know in
aitz and is sort of surrounded by you
know the German concentration camps and
everything um and even in those in that
scenario where he's got he and his
fellow inmates have no control over
anything at all at least they re retain
control over their own mind yes and over
the how they choose to approach the the
situation so even in the most extreme of
situations we can find the things that
we can control and we can focus on
controlling those and I think that's
such a nice idea from stoicism that I I
always come back to no it's very well
said I I my productivity advice from the
STS would be a question mark sh says you
have to ask yourself every moment is
this essential he says because most of
what we do and say is not essential and
he says when you eliminate the
inessential you get the double benefit
of doing the essential things better and
so when I think about how I'm able to do
what I do it's there's the things that I
don't do that I've stopped doing or that
I have delegated someone to do or that I
have brought on a team to scale being
able to do and when you get rid of the
wasted movements or the wasted thoughts
or you stop chasing the things that
don't matter or move the
needle you find that actually I mean it
takes a lot of energy to be great at
something but it's less than people
think you know what I mean like I think
maybe someone would assume that like a
writer writes 10 hours a day but it's
like two m you know what I mean um you
think that you know an athlete is
practicing and lifting weights and
training all the time but you know
they're also taking long naps during the
day and you know what and they and they
built a lifestyle where someone's
cooking for them and the team takes them
from place like they've also eliminated
so much of what is inessential that just
concentrated burst of the essential
thing allows them to be best in the
world at what they do absolutely and
yeah I just wanted to say thank you so
much for all your advice and tips and
stuff over the last three plus years of
of this book coming together well the
book is great and I think it's going to
crush fingers crossed but that's not a
thing I can control so I'm not going
think about it but it already did crush
the way to think about it is that it
already did crush and that it exists it
exists that would be that would be more
satisfying if this was the actual book
this is the advanced read copy that
we've sent away they're deliberately uh
very flaccid unfortunately but uh it
doesn't have the satisfying crud of a uh
or thud of a um of a hard cover but it
exists and so literally every person
that reads it even if that's seven
people and three of them are related to
you it's all extra true it's all extra
nice sweet man well thanks thank you all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye